we chic up TV is asking hi Evan and
Michael Michael on some of your videos
you've talked about how big businesses
are really just small businesses that
did the right things what are some of
those right things we should focus on
well it's very very great question the
first and most important right thing is
to open the doors to the possibility
that there is something in your life you
have never seen before and someone
inside of you you have no relationship
with its opening the doors to your
imagination your curiosity without
triggering yes but resistance but it's
only but I can but I don't but I didn't
but I never etc etc all of those things
that keep on coming up as simply excuses
why I'm unwilling to open the doors to
my imagination for fear of what might
walk in so the terror of the unknown is
what keeps everybody tiny everybody's
small shivering in their Timbers
terrified that ooh if I listen to this
madman with his Panama hat he's gonna
ask me to wear a Panama hat I don't want
to wear a Panama you see how it goes it
goes on and on and on so my gift has
been I've been blessed by the teachers
that I've had in my life to open the
doors and as I open the doors stuff
walks in my saxophone teacher said you
don't make music Michael music finds you
your job is to practice so you'll sound
stupid at the beginning and you continue
to practice and you sound a little less
stupid as you continue and you continue
to prac
and one moment the music Choza and that
happens it's such a shock when that
happens because you are completely
unprepared for it it's in fact opening
yourself up to what you're completely
unprepared for not what you're prepared
for you can't get prepared for this
you'll absolutely do the wrong thing
simply do what I'm suggesting that you
do and do it it's that simple just
freaking do it